hey there educators my name is eddie wu
i'm head teacher mathematics at
cherrybrook technology high school in
new south wales and it's my privilege to
be hosting edu tweeddaws this week and
whether you're a pre-service early
career or very experienced teacher i
hope you'll be able to take part in the
discussions this week be exposed to new
and interesting ideas in education and
even make a few friends along the way if
you're new to twitter or edu twitters
like i was last year then you might find
this whole thing a bit confusing and not
really know where to start so let me try
and give you a brief introduction to
what this whole thing is and give you a
few tips on how to make the most of it
in my head edgy tweet artist is two main
things
firstly it's the twitter account at edu
tweedles which is where you probably saw
the link to this video every week an
australian educator from a different
state and different sector of education
will take over the account and use it to
lead discussions about various education
related issues that they're passionate
about to get an idea of who's done it in
the past you can head to edutweetoz.org
and read interviews of previous hosts
if you're in education and haven't
followed the attendee tweet oz account
yet i can't recommend it strongly enough
if you're following at the very least
you'll be able to listen in on some
fantastic and relevant conversations
about education in our country it's also
more than likely that you'll be able to
connect with some amazing people whose
experiences and expertise you can
benefit from in the long run
one day as i have you might even get to
meet some of them in person which is
great fun apart from the edu tweet oz
account there's also the edu tweet oz
now if you're new to twitter then
hashtags may still be something of a
mystery to you
the easiest way to think about hashtags
is that they're a way to connect
individual tweets and links and pictures
to a broader topic if you go to twitter
and search for something like hashtag
edchat then you'll see a whole bunch of
people talking about issues and ideas in
education
edgy tweet ours as you might have
guessed is where the aussies hang out it
can sometimes be a little difficult to
keep track of everything so when i'm at
my desk i use tweetdeck this allows you
to customize things and see everything
that you want all in one screen and it
automatically streams in new content on
anything you tell it to search for
if you're interested in learning how to
set it up but that looks a bit
intimidating then let me know and i'll
be happy to explain to get the most out
of edu twitters and the discussions that
will be happening this week the main
thing is participate
follow the account and the hashtag and
reply whenever someone interests you
retweet things that you feel are worth
remembering or sharing
favorite things that you agree with or
you think are particularly insightful
and engage with the other educators who
you see posting ask lots of questions
follow people who are in fields that
relate to you and who post things you
like and make sure you follow people you
disagree with too because one of the
best things about twitter is that it
isn't an echo chamber if you keep your
ears open you'll read lots of things
that challenge your assumptions and
practices and that's a good thing lastly
have fun it's a fantastic community to
be a part of it's full of really
supportive people and some evenings it
really does feel like everyone's just
having a great old chat in the staff
room we'd love for you to join us